you have so many moments and so many
good movies like the scene in Old School
is one of the if not my favorite moment
in the movie and most people's that's
awesome that was being a little feral
and it's just like
um you know when you get these
opportunities and you're on the set with
Will Ferrell I guess those nerves are
coming in right you're you're definitely
like oh my God I gotta be good I gotta
be [__] great I got how many takes do
you do was on something like that
oh man also Vince Bond was on set too so
it was like oh God holy [__] man you got
these two giants you know they're like I
don't want to let these guys down but
that
that was hard
um to not I think that what helped me to
not [__] up takes was
I didn't want to disappoint will I
didn't want to screw up what he was
doing so tried to stay in it
um
but the good thing was that my character
is entertained by what remember I think
he because I think once he shoots
himself in the neck with the dart I'm
like that's [__] awesome and so I was
able to at least if I if I had to play
it straight it would have been
impossible because he was adding stuff
he was adding like
you know I like you
but you crazy I didn't think when I hit
the line that he added that it kind of
gets lost as he walks away and he's like
so tired yeah yeah I'm so tired I'm
super tired dude it's so funny that I
mean I want to watch that scene again
you know what I'm talking about Ryan of
course it's just one of the most
memorable scenes in comedy history and
you're so shocking too because you know
you don't expect the gun to go off you
know he's kind of looking at it and yeah
oh what what did you say to him you go
that's [__] awesome yeah yeah and
then and I think
Phillips too right I mean he's just like
such a brilliant filmmaker but
um and it was his idea
Todd to like slow down the vocals but
the other line too like you better pull
that up man cool down
the door you're going to [__]
Darkness
so when you shop that you had no idea it
was going to be slow motion you're like
oh this will be kind of funny and when
you saw it it's a hundred times funnier
than it would ever have been I couldn't
believe it I mean I thought it was funny
but like yeah and when they did that it
was like it just changed everything
I mean it's the funniest scene in the
movie
now that I think of it no there's some
funny scenes in there there is when he's
running around naked and blue and yeah
oh there's a lot of great stuff but that
is just that it's an epic scene